schnee nimmt er gleitmittel für das geld
machen
massentourismus eine gehirn
waschmaschine
seit jahren hält der tiroler fotograf
neuss hechenblaikner seiner heimat den
spiegel vor erzählt die geschichte wie
der mensch die berge zur freizeit
fabriken dort nur eine unsitte der
österreicher wir laden neues herrchen
bleibt nach adelboden am tag vor dem
großen weltcup event sein besucher passt
zeigt es schwarz auf weiß
hier ist er teil einer gäste industrie
der tiroler zeigt uns was sein
geschultes auge entdeckt
inszenieren und dieses platzes sie
anschauen so könnte ich jede symbolik
eines hochaltars erkennen hier
übertragen hat auf der modernen
konsumgesellschaft landschaft
verschmilzt mit taube logos in einer
unheimlichen verdichtung nicht in den
schmutz ziehen will er die branche nur
zeigen was ist los hechenblaikner ist
dennoch ein schreckgespenst für viele
touristiker er bekämpft die auswüchse
des fremdenverkehrs mit dem
insiderwissen des tirolers der in einem
gastrobetrieb aufwuchs was du jeden tag
siehst was irgendwann nicht mehr sehen
und das glaube ich für mich war ganz
wesentlicher zugange gewesen wo ich mir
auch gedacht habe bleibe ich jetzt an
wahrnehmungs verlust oder sind es die
anderen musiker selbst auch infrage
stellen weil ich als fotograf habe auch
nicht das recht als visueller scharf
rechts aufzutreten
aber wenn man es dann konnte mir die
verfolgt und inzwischen ist auch das
feedback entsprechen dass ich zumindest
weiß dass ich nicht ganz verrückt bin
nicht nur die drastischen aspekte von
konsum landschaften wecken seiner
aufmerksamkeit sondern ebenso das
unscheinbare am rad los hechenblaikner
ist auch ein stil und milieu forschender
unbedingt anlieferung einer trinkt
mischmaschine für das große fest es ist
das einzige modell dieser art in der
schweiz
der besitzer entsprechend stolz wie mit
der bank überrannt laut strenge
gebraucht meine paroli bieten
unglaublich schnell keeper hinterlasst
und den gast belasten
die geistige belastung sehr schneller
sport manager 500 spx fertig zu
verdienen
ein teil der tiroler kulturgeschichte
vernünftig
es hat doch wie mit der injektion von
einem c-rohr ganz nach unten
da die hölle also mir wundert es
überhaupt nicht dass so was ein tiroler
hervorgebracht hat nachdem tirol so was
wie die mutter stellte der bauausschuss
industrie geworden ist
was sagt uns das kleber und logos der
spitze kann aus ausgleich und welchen
bleibt man in tirol den alpinen promille
gürtel in seiner heimat hat er sich mit
solchen bildern viele feinde geschaffen
ausstellen kann er praktisch nur im
ausland
er aber versteht sich als einer der
seine heimat liebt und gerade deshalb
genau hinschaut im festgelände dann
montiert er seine großbildkamera das
zwingt zu klare position und geduldigem
vorgehen das ist ihm wichtig hab es
verdient dass wir zu werben
geselligkeit und humor gehören zu seinem
naturell
doch sein anliegen ist ernst er will die
dinge zum besseren verändert tourismus
wird dann spannend wenn jemand etwas die
welt setzt eine weitere generation sagen
kann wir bauen darauf an auf bisschen
stolz auf unsere väter auf unsere
vorfahren was sie gemacht haben und dann
sind sie schöpfen menschen das ist
schöpferische touristiker weil sie etwas
hinten lassen
im positiven sinne und nicht meinen
kontostand weil das ist mir zu wenig
neues herrchen blaikner verlässt
adelboden im schweizer tourismus ortet
er behäbigkeit in tirol
schrankenlosigkeit besser oder
schlechter
ein pauschales urteil marke nicht fällen
die szenen des festes am nächsten tag
jedenfalls die sind überall in etwa die
gleiche